et si les zones les plus touchées de
france n'étaient pas les mieux servis
par la vaccination
malgré un rythme des injections à la
hausse avec plus de 20 millions déjà
réalisés
des écarts de répartition des doses à
l'échelle des départements montre que le
gouvernement a oublié une fois encore
les plus précaires dans la lignée du
constat établi lors du premier
confinement en termes d'inégalités les
territoires les plus fragiles ceux là
même où le virus circule encore à
vitesse grand v demeure encore et
toujours les grands perdants
il suffit pour cela de se pencher
quelques instants sur les statistiques
départementales en date du 21 avril la
seine-et-marne comptait 12 5% de
personnes vaccinées contre 28-36 en
corse du sud ou encore 24,7 en ariège
d'une manière générale lé département à
dominante rurale est faiblement peuplées
sont les plus avancés à linverse les
zones urbaines demeure à la traîne
pourtant elles les autorités sanitaires
affirment que la répartition des doses
et rééquilibrer en fonction de l'état
sanitaire des territoires encore une
fois on constate que la réalité sur le
terrain est tout autre
le département du rhône par exemple où
le taux d'incidence et est de 425
nouveaux cas pour 100000 habitants la
semaine du 21 avril a été moins bien
doté que le territoire de belfort où le
taux d'incidence était pourtant
inférieure
si on rapporte le nombre de doses
livrées à la population départementale
et à la situation épidémique
on observe que des départements très
fortement touchée reçoivent
proportionnellement moins de doses que
d'autres où la situation est plus
favorable à l'image de la
seine-saint-denis et de la scène et m'a
donné la priorité aux personnes d'un
certain âge peut en effet posé problème
quant à l'efficacité de la nuit contre
le colis 19 si on exclut de cette
stratégie le facteur économique et
social dans les zones les plus pauvres
où le virus circule le plus le
gouvernement a choisi de ne pas garder
de critères de pauvreté dans sa
stratégie vaccinale
on ne peut que le regretter le taux de
vaccination population générale n'a pas
beaucoup de sens
même si la cible se concentre sur les
personnes âgées la part des vaccinés est
en seine et marne et en seine saint
denis plus faible que dans la creuse ou
dans le doubs
car ce sont des départements plus jeune
alors que la moyenne d'âge en
réanimation à l'échelle nationale est
d'environ 60 ans elle est en
seine-saint-denis de 47 ans pour avoir
une limite
élevé il faut un pourcentage de
vaccinées élevées en faisant l'impasse
sur de nombreux facteurs notamment
économiques et sociaux le gouvernement
semble décidé à maintenir la feuille de
route du président de la république
quitte à creuser un peu plus les
disparités dans les départements les
plus touchés se serait bien passé